bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 28 mai
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro de file echo votre magazine qui
revient sur l'actualité économique
locale
on commence au site avec les titres de
cette édition dans l'actualité de cette
semaine le conseil départemental a
présenté sa politique en faveur de
l'insertion socioprofessionnelle nous
reviendrons sur la convention qui a été
signée avec pôle emploi mais dépôt-vente
yvelinois son petit nom crise depuis
plusieurs années leur nombre ne cesse de
diminuer dans les yvelines comme à
versailles où la fée et le lutin un
dépôt vente pour enfants est dans une
situation difficile
c'est un nul confidentiel est un métier
de confiance dont nous allons vous
parler dans les métiers de la semaine
éric parsy et marchand de chevaux il est
accepté de nous parler de sa profession
et cette semaine dans l'entretien la
semaine nous avons parlé du greta le
greta fête ses 40 ans le greta ce sont
les structures de l'éducation nationale
qui organise des formations pour adultes
dont la plupart des métiers on peut y
préparer un diplôme où ils suivre une
simple un simple module de formation
avec nous pour en parler en plateau
aujourd'hui à marylène pons
bonsoir bonjour pardon vous êtes
conseiller en formation continue au
greta des civils nous reviendrons donc
avec vous sur l'émission les actions
mais aussi l'avenir du greta mme avant
cela passe en revue l'actualité
communiqué de la semaine
le conseil départemental a présenté
cette semaine sa politique en faveur de
l'insertion socioprofessionnelle une
convention a ainsi été signée avec pôle
emploi facilitant la coordination des
services l'insertion professionnelle
dans les yvelines va aussi s'articuler
autour d'activités une agence
d'insertion mais aussi la création d'une
auto école sociale
regardez ce reportage de même côté et
patrick jacques de dixmude à multiples
signature ce matin entre le conseil
départemental pôle emploi et l'état pour
permettre une meilleure coordination des
services départementaux et de pôle
emploi
plusieurs signatures mais un seul but
l'insertion socioprofessionnelle des
personnes les plus en difficulté les
chômeurs longue durée
ces dix personnes qui ont ils sont
confrontés à des difficultés de logement
des difficultés sociales diffuser de
garde d'enfants des personnes qui sont
risque d'expulsion par exemple ou des
personnes sur des problématiques de
santé importantes 1200 personnes
devraient être accompagnées d'ici l'été
par les 17 employés de pôle emploi
associé à des binômes issue du conseil
départemental les yvelines ont vu une
très forte augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active
autre cible de cette politique avec près
de 38 % en cinq ans le rsa représente 10
% du budget du département
j'ai pas de voiture j'habite en grande
couronne il n'y a pas de gars là où
j'habite
donc je peux pas trouver un emploi
comme j'ai pas d'emploi je peux pas
trouver un logement ou comme j'ai pas
d'emploi je peux pas acheter une voiture
et voilà et tout ça fait que on va
essayer d'apporter par réponse point
parfois mes réponses en même temps deux
autres initiatives ont été présentés ce
matin la création d'une auto école
sociale et le lancement d'activités une
agence d aide à l'emploi c'est du
personnel de la collectivité mise à
disposition donc aujourd'hui l'agencé
neuf personnes au niveau de versailles
mais on en train de constituer des
équipes sur les territoires pour qu'elle
soit en relation étroite avec les
collectivités avec les associations avec
tous les partenaires qui travaillent en
direction des hommes de la question de
l'emploi activités aura une voire deux
équipes sur saint quentin en yvelines
pôle emploi a recensé 80 7880 chômeurs
dans les yvelines pour le mois de mars
2015 et transport à présent une réunion
avait lieu ce mercredi soir à guyancourt
concernant la ligne 18 du grand paris
express ligne qui doit relier orly et
versailles chantiers en passant par
saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 400 personnes étaient présentes
l'occasion de se pencher sur les coûts
engendrés par ce projet de super métro
automatique autour de paris
il devrait coûter 22 6 milliards d'euros
mais pour pouvoir a circulé la ligne 18
il faudra être patient la mise en
service n'est pas avant une dizaine
d'années enfin la ville le 2 juillet en
josas fête le bicentenaire d'eau berck
ans le fondateur de la manufacture
royale à cette occasion plusieurs clubs
d'entrepreneurs se sont donné rendez
vous jeudi dernier pour la première
rencontre interclubs du territoire sur
le thème l'entrepreneuriat d'oberkampf à
aujourd'hui
objectif échanger sur les clés du succès
de l'entrepreneuriat dans un monde en
mutation
en prenant pour exemple une figure
locale et marquantes comme nous
l'expliqué michel boucher lamontagne
président du club des entrepreneurs de
jouy en josas berck enfin était un
employeur sociale
certains disent que c'est un des
inventeur de la sécurité sociale on a
également regardé les aspects
commercialisation des idées par exemple
ou bien quand ça a été le premier à se
dire qu'il valait mieux constitué destin
donc il a inventé la vente sur stocks
plutôt que de produire à la commande ce
qui était le cas précédemment
les entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
doivent avoir négocié un contrat de
génération dans lequel figure un volet
transmission des savoirs et des
compétences une réunion 7 sur 7
thématiques et est organisée par la
maison de l'emploi de la formation et le
club fasse le plus échangé sur les
bonnes pratiques
catherine du gâteau assystem 12000
collaborateurs dont 7000 en france une
moyenne d'âge de 36 ans c'est jeune
pourtant la question de la transmission
des savoirs et des compétences se pose
pour cette multinationale spécialisée
dans le nucléaire et qui ouvre 1500
recrutement cette année
aujourd'hui assist mc est né dans les
années soixante soixante six exactement
dans les métiers liés au nucléaire donc
on a des experts qui sont rentrés dans
la société
dans ces années là qui ont construit les
centrales et aujourd'hui on est sur le
démantèlement des centrales
donc du coup c'est eux qu'on le compte
toute la technicité de ce qui s'est
passé il ya plus de 40 ans et pour
transmettre ces savoirs depuis 2008
l'entreprise a mis en place des
instituts de formation s'est accompagnée
d'un programme dédié aux apprentis d'un
principe de compagnonnage et de
parrainage
il n'y a pas d'obligation légale en la
matière mais les entreprises de plus de
300 salariés sont censés avoir négocié
un contrat de génération qui intègre ce
volet transmission des compétences et
sur ce plan tout n'est pas si simple
c'est pas inné de transmettre tout le
monde n'a pas et ni la volonté ni la
capacité à transmettre ça se prépare ça
s'organise déjà faire un état des lieux
l'association voir ce qu'on transmet
dans quel objectif
et puis préparer les acteurs pour
transmettre et formaliser les choses et
les tuteurs et
les apprenants qui vont aussi recevoir
voilà ses compétences pour organiser
organiser tout ça c'est une vraie
question aujourd'hui de dire comment je
me permets à ma société et aux
collaborateurs qui sont dans ma société
de transmettre du coup leur savoir que
ce soit des savoir être des savoir faire
comme en jeu leur permet du coup de
donner du coup soit d une jeune
génération soit à des personnes qui
changent de métier c'est ces
informations là et comment je les rends
aussi à l'aise à transmettre ces
informations
une réunion d'information est organisée
par la maison de l'emploi le club face à
la demande des entreprises
l'idée c'était d'avoir un expert
spécialiste de cette question
donc nous avons fait appel pour cela à
l'aract ile de france et également
d'avoir des témoignages d'entreprises
donc des choses beaucoup plus concrètes
qui permettent puisque c'est aussi une
demande des entreprises de pouvoir
échanger les bonnes pratiques et en la
matière le premier conseil à donner aux
entreprises
identifier les compétences à transmettre
et avoir un regard sur la pyramide des
âges de sa société pour ne pas attendre
le dernier moment les conseils peuvent
être repris sur le site de l'aract la
maison de l'emploi
certes également de relais et nous
allons parler maintenant de formation
continue pour les adultes avec
l'entretien la semaine s'est tout de
suite
je le rappelle nous sommes en plateau
avec marylène pons qui est conseillère
en formation continue au greta des
yvelines alors le greta je le rappelle
c'est un groupement d'établissements
publics d'enseignement qui mutualisent
leurs compétences et leurs moyens pour
proposer les formations continues pour
les adultes alors marienne maryland ont
sa mission du greta c'est avant tout
d'accompagner d'aliou sow de leur offrir
un nouveau moyen de se former c'est ça
oui c'est ça alors on peut avoir des
adultes à partir de 17 18 ans bien sûr
qu'ils sortent un peu du système
scolaire et qui a envie d'aller se
former des adultes en contrat de
professionnalisation par exemple on peut
avoir des adultes qui ont eu un autre
métier qui veulent se reconvertir au
travers d'un fonds jai cif congé
individuel de la formation peut avoir
des demandeurs d'emploi aussi par pôle
emploi puisqu'on a un certain nombre de
deux formations qui sont financés par la
région par pôle emploi
et puis des individuels qui ont besoin
de se former sur des champs plus
spécifiques et plus pointus alors vous
venez de fêter vos 40 ans oui il est
important qu est ce que ça signifie
voilà pour le greta de cet anniversaire
alors c'est très important parce que 40
ans ma 40 ans d'existence et puis encore
certainement 40 ans de plus si ce n'est
plus et en même temps nous nous allons
fêter leurs comptes mans c'est à dire
sur les yvelines nous étions nous sommes
nous étions 2° tasset dans l'évier
universel formation et nous nous
regroupons à partir du 1er septembre
pour faire un seul creta départementale
40 ans et donc voilà une longue période
existence puisque on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on change plus facilement
métier oui bon ça c'est évident déjà
marché du travail
les structures les organisations des
entreprises les nouveaux métiers
le fait de se former sur thur deschamps
plus pointues et puis les opportunités
qu'il faut savoir saisir maintenant
parce quelqu'un mondialisation on
circule tout autour de la terre dans les
pays européens où vers les états unis il
faut être capable de boucher oui les
personnes qui voient là veulent faire
une formation au greta sont des gens qui
ne trouvent pas de travail dans leur
secteur et qui sont obligés de se
personne est obligée un bien sûr mais je
pense qu'à une réelle motivation et on
travaille beaucoup sur le projet de la
personne sa motivation en entretien et
les voir les débouchés qui sont aussi
pour elle alors justement comment ça se
passe si on veut voilà changer météo
avoir justement une formation de l'état
comment quelles démarches on fait
comment ça se passe ensuite par contact
donc soit sont des formations qui sont
proposées par la région
donc ils ont eu accès à ces formations
par l'intermédiaire de pôle emploi par
eux-mêmes ils ont été sur les sites
comme défi métier où ils viennent à
dépendamment nous contacter et puis nous
leur disons ce qui est possible de faire
comment on peut travailler ensemble on
peut les positionner et on vérifie
toujours projet professionnel
quels diplômes on peut obtenir grâce au
greta
alors on peut aller du crp au bts l'un
principalement sur des sur des
formations diplômantes alors diplômante
certifiant l'éducation nationale
ministère de la santé mon ministère du
travail
et puis sur des parcours plus
professionnalisant avec une attestation
compétences ce qui est justement d'aider
des adaptations s'adapte par rapport à
la perte anticipée exerce encore son
métier alors bien sûr la formation pour
adultes s'est jouée de dire presque une
forme d'individualisation on s'adapte
l'adulte n'apprend pas comme un plus
jeune
il est plus motivé il a déjà un certain
nombre de bagages derrière lui donc
automatiquement les formateurs s'adapter
est ce que justement les publics
concernés mais aussi des gens qui
veulent complètement changé de métier
comme on le voit la régulation
professionnelle et bien justement aux 40
ans d'héritages avait invité deux
personnes un monsieur qui travaille dans
l'informatique mandant les quinzaines
d'années et une dame
chez orange et cette dame participer à
notre un autre fait puisqu'elle avait un
food trucks
elle a pu enfin faire la formation qui
lui convenait c'est à dire le sap et
cuisine pâtissier est venu compléter le
buffet qui avait été organisée pour ses
40 ans à douala beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes comme ça ils fallout iv
justement là pas de souci justement la
crise a fait partir des formations les
plus demandées oui la cuisine le
bâtiment et le sanitaire et social est
ce que vous vous orientez aussi les
personnes qui veulent se former ce qu'on
appelle heures les les stagiaires c'est
sagem un rapport au contexte économique
au milieu qui marche mieux au secteur
qui m'ont gestion parce que si on a plus
de formation financée par la région ça
correspond à un besoin identifié donc
généralement c'est là dessus sur sur sur
les tendances du marché qui sont donnés
par par la région et les formations
conventionnées parce que tout le monde
n'a pas le la possibilité de s'offrir
une formation sur un an ce qui atteste
des gens qui s'imaginent voilà vouloir
changer avant de formation et qui ont
fait des réticences qu'est ce que vous
leur diriez dans ce cas là je leur dirai
d'y aller ne pas hésiter parce que comme
je dis souvent la terre tourne il faut
qu'on reste sur la terre et qu'on avance
avec la société et tous ces changements
qu'il faut y aller il faut venir nous
voir
et justement par rapport voilà vous avez
donc fêter vos 40 ans comment s'annonce
le futur tu verrais pas eh bien le futur
s'annonce bien donc on va se regrouper
on s'affaire une entité départementale
avec une visibilité plus accessible un
seul lieu
et puis des antennes sur tout le
territoire pour déployer nos formations
justement donc voilà des nouvelles les
initiatives vont être mises en place
je le rappel voici voulez plus
d'information sur le greta un site
internet www.gva.ch versailles point fr
merci beaucoup
marylène pons est devenu son
tribulations pour nous parler
du greta nous continuons notre mission
avec le chiffre de la semaine qui est
également sur le greta
20 1421 c'est le nombre de stagiaires
donc de personnes en formation qui sont
passés par les greta de l'académie de
versailles en 2013 cette même année 624
bilan de compétences ont été réalisés et
le taux de réussite et de certification
des stagiaires au diplôme a été 2 92%
je vous propose maintenant de passer à
leur parti le magazine avec l'entreprise
de la semaine
connaissez-vous les dépôts-ventes ce
sont des magasins vous pouvez vendre des
choses dont vous voulez plus et acheter
de nouveaux articles de deuxième main ou
parfois quasiment neuf avec la mode des
brocantes la tendance à chiner on
pourrait penser que ces commerces
connaissent un certain succès pourtant
dans les yvelines ce n'est pas forcément
le cas il ferme de plus en plus de
dépôt-vente nous sommes allés à
versailles dans l'un des derniers encore
ouvert il s'appelle la fée lutins il
connaît une situation difficile regardez
ce reportage réalisé avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et romain respect
pour le montage
ça c'est du deux ans aux huit ans sur
cet endroit là quelques explications
pour aiguiller une cliente un peu perdu
pourtant les dépôts-ventes entrent de
plus en plus dans la routine des
consommateurs on y trouve plus seulement
des meubles ou des antiquités acheteurs
ou vendeurs chacun a ses raisons d'y
venir
on vend des choses en achètent des
choses oui oui oui
avant d'acheter neuf on regarde toujours
s'il ya s'il n'y a pas ce qui nous
intéresse d'occasions
j'ai eu des jumelles et donc j'ai des
produits particuliers au double je n'ai
pas envie de le jeter je voulais rendre
ici j'ai le service je peux déposer et
après je ne peux plus m'en occuper je
préfère toucher directement ou
indirectement et acheter directement ma
propre
voilà maintenant il y en a pas beaucoup
dans le coin que sa fille lui avait
plutôt un centre pour messi
paradoxalement si cette nouvelle façon
de consommer s'avère tendance dans les
yvelines les dépôts-ventes ferment les
uns après les autres
astrid syrie a ouvert le sien il ya deux
ans et demi elle touche un petit
pourcentage sur ce que ces déposants
thuillez et vend aussi des articles
neufs
malgré sa clientèle fidèle elle pourrait
bientôt devoir fermer boutique
on va vous demander des charges
exorbitantes pour un t-shirt par exemple
à 4 euros vous avez un euro qui vous
rentre dans la caisse avec ça il faut
payer les charges de loyer
accessoirement un salaire c'est pas
possible du tout donc il faudrait que
l'état revoie vraiment sérieusement le
système des dépôts vente puisque tout le
monde ferme les uns derrière les autres
en l'espace de deux ans et demi où je
suis ouverte il y en a six dans la
région qui ont fermé des charges lourdes
liées au régime du rs
si le régime social des indépendants de
france auquel les propriétaires de dépôt
vente sont soumis il serait trop onéreux
selon le syndicat national du commerce
de l'antiquité de l'occasion et de
galeries d'art il ya quand même une
manifestation qui s'est déroulée le 9
mars devant l'assemblée nationale
à ce sujet puisqu'il y avait trop de
charges et puis on ne sait pas et on
nous par rapport à une réalisation ce
traditionnel où on a 2 ou 3 % de frais
de gestion là on est plutôt dans des
choix de gestion qui sont de l'ordre de
10 ou 12%
donc c'est quand même normal des choses
qui sont pas bien juteux et ce n'est pas
l'unique problème la concurrence
d'internet et les sites de troc ou de
vente de particulier à particulier sont
autant de facteurs qui affaiblissent les
dépôts ventes les prix du marché sont
ainsi cassé par des non professionnels
et cela touche même des secteurs comme
la décoration ou l'ameublement
je trouve que c'est plus compliqué
aujourd'hui qu'il ya cinq ans donc c'est
pas cette plus en plus compliqué à cause
d'internet et le de la crise la crise
économique puisque bon on est bon départ
nous dit kane reprise aujourd'hui on la
voit pas en la sent pas bon alors ce qui
me concerne ici bien que j'ai perdu des
concurrents dans le secteur
sur les 5 si jamais tout autour je vous
en moins de clients que l'année dernière
alors les yvelinois pas suffisamment
adepte des dépôts-ventes la situation
reste très variable d'un territoire à
l'autre
en france il existe plus de 13000 dépôt
vente le chiffre d'affaires du secteur
dépasse les deux milliards d'euros
vous aimez les chevaux ça tombe bien on
en parle tout de suite
éric parsy est un expert du monde équin
depuis plus de 40 ans il exerce une
profession peu commune celle de marchand
de chevaux
c'est donc pas par hasard qui s'est
installée dans le département des
yvelines
véritable terre de cheval qui facilite
son commerce nous l'avons suivi lors
d'une rencontre avec un client afin d'en
savoir un peu plus sur sa profession
yolaine thorez et elodie moines éric
parsy reçoit son client chez lui dans la
commune yvelinoise de la
queue-lez-yvelines ensemble ils
discutent du profil des chevaux qui
seront présentés tout à l'heure était
plutôt un show sanguin le pain complet
donc un gros filet mais ce rôle france
d'une martingale fait plutôt plutôt un
peu froid éric parsy exerce un métier
peu connu celui de marchand de chevaux
il évalue les animaux les négocie les
achète et les présente à la vente
une passion qu'il exerce depuis plus de
40 ans et qui fait de lui un véritable
expert aujourd'hui pour moi au niveau
d'emploi pas de temps à perdre
eric va faire tester ses chevaux à son
client dans une écurie quelques
kilomètres plus loin
chez lui il ne s'agit que d'une écurie
de transit n'ayant pas les installations
nécessaires pour faire travailler les
animaux et sont entretenus et valoriser
ici par des cavaliers
alors celui ci le père et un fils de la
louve et du roi de la mer fait d'armes
de robben fonds de dix ans bruno le
client cherche un cheval facile à monter
pour faire des concours il s'est alors
tourné vers eric qu'il connaît depuis
bon nombre d'années
c'est un ensemble de choses pour
guincher un cheval qu'est ce que vous
regardez là par exemple vous qu'il soit
agréable tout simplement pour tous pas
regardé à manipuler la montée et
confortable après avoir scellé présenter
le cheval aux clients direction la
carrière le client observe d'abord
l'animal avec son cavalier avant de
monter à son tour faire aux deux
allers-retours monsieur comme ça c'est
beaucoup de cars et des témoins très
bien à cheval abîme qu'ils peuvent ou
masquées sont loin d'ailleurs pas
forcément défaut du cheval etc
vous ne vous en rendez compte que quand
vous montez dessus lors de l'essai eric
se fait toujours discret et laisse son
client se faire sa propre opinion mais
grâce à son expertise
il devine rapidement si le contact passe
entre les deux le trail des toniques
date un peu trop on va dire on va les
voir l'autre bruno ne semblent pas
convaincus par ce premier essai d'après
lui la monture correspond mieux à son
cavalier actuelle du poney ou cheval de
compétition éric achète et revend des
chevaux de selle de tous types un métier
auquel il a été initié dès son plus
jeune âge lorsqu'il a croisé la route
d'un marchand de chevaux en normandie
c'est comme dans n'importe quel commerce
le bénéfice se fait à l'achat si le
cheval est bien acheté automatiquement
vous en tirer un bénéfice minimum qui
vous permet d'en but environ 3000 euros
pour un cheval de promenade plus de 5000
euros pour un cheval de compétition
les prix varient par rapport à la
régularité de leur performance par
exemple la négociation entre aussi en
jeu
quand vous avez un cheval qui est bien
dressés qui recule qui appuient qui
change de pied qui se met en place et il
ya toujours des clients très gentille
qui est facile à monter etc
il ya toujours des clients pour pour
acheter 50 c'est un type de cheval était
quand même recherché depuis 1972 il
connaît les besoins et a su se
constituer un véritable réseau
éric yvan la plupart de ces animaux en
europe et achètent principalement en
france pays d'élevage dont le diamant
cavaliers depuis plusieurs mois de ses
deux chevaux antoine s'est attaché à eux
mais il en est conscient
ils peuvent être vendus du jour au
lendemain a quitté son écurie ça me
touche un petit peu mais
on est dans l'obligation de vendre des
chevaux pour gagner sa vie donc il faut
bien qu'ils parti doit partir là il
parle à l'essai continue avec le
deuxième cheval dans l'air de bien se
passer si vous voulez prendre la
combinaison tout de suite
eric le voit son client semble mieux
s'accorder avec ce cheval dans ce genre
d'histoire là ont proposé puis le
l'acheteur dispose d'un soleil plus de
son choix
mais c'est vrai qu'il accorde bien là
que je préfère ce show là parce que
d'abord il saute plus en ligne
il brille pas et j'ai des meilleures
sensations dessus bruno doit voir
d'autres chevaux avant de faire son
choix
il reviendra peut-être le tester d'ici
quelques semaines en attendant eric
profil de sa monture quelques jours ou
quelques mois il ne garde jamais ses
chevaux très longtemps répartis dans
toute la france et en comptent parfois
jusqu'à 70 des choses qui sont
particulièrement attachant et caetera et
j'ai monté aussi un petit peu en
concours comme ça tu sais de chevaux
tu peux quand y pense même que c'est la
règle du jeu donc non pour faire avec
depuis ses débuts ce passionné ne compte
plus les chevaux qui l'a acheté et vendu
sûrement des milliers la retraite il n'y
pense même pas tant que la santé lui
permet il continuera pour la fin de
notre émission avant de nous quitter je
propose de regarder avec moi la jambe à
la semaine de rendez vous cette semaine
mais il faudra vous décidez car ils sont
tous les ils ont tous les deux eu lieu
le lundi 1er juin
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines propose un atelier d'une
journée sur le thème du changement de
métier nous en parlons tout à l'heure
l'atelier commence à 9 heures et finit à
17h30
aidée par un conseiller vous pourrez
réfléchi établir une liste de vos
compétences et en réfléchir pour votre
transfert
il faut s'inscrire pour participer à
cette solide à cet atelier qui sera
suivie d'une seconde séance
enfin le deuxième rendez vous c'est un
qu'une conférence débat qui a lui
également ce lundi 1er juin à 18h30 à
l'hôtel de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sur le thème de la
transmission d'entreprise s'est animée
par le medef des civils
et là aussi il faut s'inscrire c'est la
fin de notre émission je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée et vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de fil écho au revoir